it's been a 55 year process up up until
this day and I used to play drums in
Clarks band and that with Justin and and
that's kind of how this whole thing
started in the beginning so yeah it's
been an amazing it just started off
actually with the men and a mate a guy
called Adam Hart who's a director of
photography for the film who's here
tonight too and yeah in from Australia
and yeah we were surfing one day and we
an Australian documentary channel had
approached me about doing a short piece
about myself and Clark's friendship and
it fell through and unfortunately but I
was talking to add while we're having a
surf and said made I feel like it's a
missed opportunity and he said mate well
maybe we could just do it ourselves and
so we paddled in made a plan and say
that yeah and then then just bought some
tickets and a camera and came over to
the states and started shooting yeah
that was five years ago Justin what a
treat an honor to meet you and
congratulations on this watching you
ramp up for the monk competition was
wonderful and and and painful seeing how
anxious you were what was it like adding
cameras to that entire process and into
this process of opening up your life
well when Al had approached me about
having me as a character in this this
documentary that he was working on my
response was well it's al as my buddy I
don't think anybody's going to see it so
sure you could follow me around you know
that's great we'll hang out and and it
just kept on developing and it was I
think before the competition when when I
realized that they were going to be
there I was a little worried about
having the cameras but it was actually
really good to have Hicks there because
he's a good buddy of mine so I was you
know it was nice to have him around even
even
when it wasn't going so well it was you
know he was there filming but he was
also there was my friend so I mean I
think it made it a little bit I guess
not as weird as I thought it would be
you know if that makes any sense but it
was quite a journey and and and I you
know I couldn't imagine having anybody
else around to do that then ow I think
I've grown to be a little more
comfortable with the process and
realizing that's a snapshot of where I
was but there's we all we all know
moments where I cringe oh that again but
you deal with it you move on you know
that was me then and hopefully me now is
a little bit better it's amazing of the
words keep coming back and every time I
see this film because it makes me cry
every time I see it it's in it's just so
much shriya truth in it we couldn't make
this up I've been 13 years old and then
having them come join my damn when I'm
26 and meeting Justin late in gel so we
have a amazing group of young people
that we travel with all over the world
every year called the global gumbo
all-stars and man they are the young
people taking music back where it
belongs all down to 12 years old we got
a little girl named Emily bared it right
first symphony orchestras since she was
five years old obama calls baby Mozart
anyway they do not play you know this
one does not play either candy plays a
little bit but not not not Justin I'm
serious it's amazing the Cuban piano
player Alfred Rodriguez he practices 14
hours a day it's ridiculous Nikki
Yanofsky we got a Slovakian guitar
player Andre his party who George Benson
just took to open the theater Olympic
theatre with him in Paris and in New
York he played like to George when he
was 10 years old anyway I'm saying all
this to build up to my brother here
Justin and it's just astounding to me
it's the most rewarding thing I could
have a blessing to have in my life
because they put me on the shoulders
when I was young and have a chance to do
that with them it's just the most
exciting
thing I've ever done in my life it's a
credible and having this dude thank you
can name real when I studied in Paris
with naughty people on stage she always
used to tell us and I see chevensky
there Copeland Steve Reich you know
Bernstein and sits a Quincy your music
can never be more or less than yours a
human being and that's very true and
that's enough supplies of my brother
here that's who they are as people as
real people with no BS that's what I
love I've never worked on anything like
this film it is just from a land ad and
Justin Quincy everybody involved our
editor everybody came to the film with
this passion and this love you know and
wanting to do this respectful beautiful
story about Clark they all want to honor
and and pay respect to Clark and and
that brought the tone through the whole
project and so it was pretty
overwhelming when Al kept adding songs
and more songs and more songs I'm like
that's miles davis you know we don't
have that money but you know oh yeah for
all the clearances and the footage and
you know and he kept coming up with
these great clips that you know it was
like I found this great clip of Duke
Ellington and I'm like I'm thin my head
thinking how we gonna pay for this you
know and there's music in it and but you
know it was every piece was important to
the story and important to building the
characters and letting the audience know
who these people are and and what
they've done it their lives and then
what we kept finding was that that
goodwill was in everything we did you
know licensing everybody we reach out to
they say oh I love Clark I'd love to
help and you know it's just it's one of
those projects that is a community
effort you know group effort everybody
had the best intentions and and and you
know in working with Quincy and him
being a student of Clark's as well I
mean these are Clark students you know
all together and it's crazy but it's so
beautiful you know i mean this is this
is the team and everybody wanting to
thank their teacher in this film
and and that's I think it comes across
for the audience when they're watching
it we originally were just trying to do
Clark's life story you know a bit of a
biopic on him and everybody we would
interview they'd say he's the greatest
trumpet player and flugelhorn player in
the world and the greatest teacher and
then but I was never able to cap capture
that in just interviews because from
what I'd seen that generosity that clark
had that i I've never ever seen it in
anybody that was that strong and I
haven't gone down that path a little bit
with Clark you know I I often wondered
why does he believe in me you know and
after interviewing some of these greats
they said the same thing I never knew
why Clarke believed in me and bed so
that's like baller was saying it's a way
of us just saying thank you to our
teacher you know